قالت السفاره السعوديه في لبنان انها تلقت
بلاغا من نوع من ذوي احد المواطنين عن
فقدان الاتصال به منذ يوم امس الاحد اثناء
وجوده في العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت اضافت
السفاره في بيان لها انها تتواصل مع
السلطات الامنيه اللبنانيه على اعلى
المستويات لكشف ملابسات اختفاء المواطن في
حين ذكرت قناه الاخباريه السعوديه في
تغريده على حسابها ان المواطنه السعوديه
المختطف في لبنان يعملون لصالح الخطوط
الجويه السعوديه في بيروت وان الاختطاف
جرى مساء امس الاحد وسط المنطقه التجاريه
في العاصمه اللبنانيه مضيفه ان الخاطفين
بعثوا رساله هاتفيه صادره من الضاحيه
الجنوبيه في بيروت مقر حزب الله طالبوا
فيها بفديه بقيمه 400 الف دولار
من جانبه قال وزير الداخليه اللبناني في
حكومه تصريف الاعمال بسام ملوي انه يتابع
مع شعبه المعلومات بقوى الامن الداخليه
قضيه اختطاف مواطن سعودي في بيروت اضاف
مولوي في تغريده على حسابه انه على تواصل
بادق التفاصيل مع السفير السعودي واصفا ما
جرى بانه يمس بعلاقه بلاده مع اشقائه
العربه كما اكد ان عقاب الفاعلين سيكون
قاسيا على حد وصفه
ينضم الينا من بيروت مراسل جزيره ايهاب
العقد ايهاب تفاصيل عمليات الاختطاف هذه
هو ماذا تقول حكومه تصريف الاعمال كيف
تتفاعل مع هذا الخبر
حتى الان لا تفاصيل امنيه حول طبيعه الخطف
واين جرى لكن الثابت انه حصل منذ اكثر من
24 ساعه وزير الداخليه بسام مولوي توعد
الخاطفين بانه سيضرب يد من حديد واعتبر ان
هذا الامر يمس العلاقات اللبنانيه
السعوديه
وتوعد كذلك بعقاب قاس لمن قاموا بهذه
العمليه
القوى الامنيه وتحديدا شعبه المعلومات منذ
تبلغها بعمليه الخطف
تحركت بسرعه وهي تطبع لقوى الامن الداخلي
وتقوم بتحريات وتبحث عن
المخطوف من قبل الخاطفين الذين رصدت او
رصدت رصد هاتف المخطوف في عدد من المناطق
في العاصمه بيروت ويجري تجري عمليات
مداهمه بحثا عنه القوى الامنيه الان يمكن
القول بانها لاز تعمل على تقصي الحقائق
وجمع المعلومات
ومطارده اي مكان محتمل لوجود المخطوف
السعودي في لبنان ايضا السلطات الامنيه
الاخرى تقوم بتحرك مماثل وتحاول رصد مكان
المخطوف وفقا لما اعلنته وزاره الداخليه
اللبنانيه لذلك فان العمليه الامنيه
مستمره من قبل السلطات اللبنانيه التي
تقول انها لن تتهاون في عمليات الخطف في
لبنان خصوصا وان عمليات مشابهه وقعت في
عدد من المناطق اللبنانيه خلال السنوات
الماضيه وادت بمعظمها الى تحرير المخطوفين
من ايدي المافيات التي كانت قامت بعمليات
الخطف صدرت عده مواقف لبنانيه من بينها
مواقف لنواب من مختلف الانتماءات اعتبرت
ان ما جرى هو مس بالسلم الاهلي وطالبت
القوى الامنيه بالعمل على اطلاق المخطوف
السعودي في لبنان ايضا صدر موقف من مفتي
الجعفري الممتاز احمد قبلان اعتبر فيه ان
ما جرى من عمليه خطف هو من صناعه من سماهم
بالمافيات التي تقوم
بعمليات مخله بالقانون وطالب الاجهزه
الامنيه بسرعه كشف ملابسات كما جرى عمليا
السلطات الامنيه مستنفره تقوم بدوريات
بمداهمات
وقضايا تتبع امني اخرى من بينها رصد
هاتف الشخصي المخطوف وهي تقوم بما عليها
كما اكدت وزاره الداخليه اللبنانيه وايضا
هناك اهتمام سياسي بهذه المساله خصوصا وان
السفاره السعوديه في بيروت كانت اعلنت عن
عمليه الخطف وانها قامت بابلاغ جهاز فرع
المعلومات وهو جهاز استخبارات وزاره
الداخليه اللبنانيه الذي عمليا يتولى
قياده كل التتبعات الامنيه والتحقيقات
الساريه في هذا
المجال شكرا لك ايهاب العقد مراسل جزيره
كنت معنا من بيروت